je cachais les plaques
9e chez un peu de vacances puis on tombe
avec des lots complets avec la chaleur
des derniers jours ces vacanciers
étaient prêts pour la baignade mais
voilà qu'elle est interdite sur de
nombreuses plages qui bordent la baie
missisquoi
c'est en raison de la présence de ce
qu'on appelle les efflorescences de
cyanobactéries les micro organismes qui
peuvent développer des toxines chez
toxines là peuvent affecter le foie
peuvent affecter le système nerveux
peuvent causer des irritations sur la
peau des gens peuvent avoir des nausées
l'importante présence des algues bleu
vert est un coup dur pour les
commerçants qui dépendent des touristes
qu'un repas d'achalandage à la plage on
compte notre chiffre d'affaires devrait
60 à 65 pour ça mais surtout une source
d'inquiétude pour des citoyens qui
s'alimentent en eau potable dans la
bible comme ceux résidant de philipsburg
qui vit à moins de 100 mètres de l'usiné
de filtration depuis des dizaines
d'années
de son terrain il peut voir hulu épuisé
samedi l'endroit était couvert d'une
épaisse couche d'algues l'odeur du lac
était suffisante pour donner la nausée
malgré tout les autorités locales ce
pont rassurantes les techniques
actuelles permettent de filtrer l'eau
mais ce n'est pas assez selon robert
jigal bri
il croit que les autorités doivent en
faire plus pour combattre le problème
des algues à la racine mais c'est un
travail de titan puisque lé
réchauffement climatique encourage la
croissance des zags les cyanobactéries
céder les organismes qui aime énormément
la chaleur les températures plus chaudes
en 50 ans l'eau de la baie missisquoi a
déjà augmenté de 2 points 5 degrés
celsius il sait alexandrie bel et le
radio canada philipsburg